all right we were talking with Tristan
who was injured on the job and the net
result was $50,000 in debt and into a
bankruptcy and trying to figure out how
to start again I know that's a quick
summary of what you already told me
Tristan but that's where you find
yourself now you're coming out of a
chapter 7 right chapter 7 when was your
meeting of creditors meeting of
creditors was was March so you're done
like seven so I'm done yeah predators
okay so yeah so you have no debt right
you have no doubt unless you had IRS or
student loans and my wife's the only one
with student loans
I have no student loans my wife I got
was you need to get a little scholarship
to go to real uh I'm a realtor so she's
in class now as we speak saying like six
weeks and she'll be able to attain her
license okay that was so hot and how can
I best help you today
I just don't know from my point I mean
I'm on that workers comp I'm 33 years
old and I might have to go on federal
disability retirement or Social Security
disability and I just I want to see how
I can myself you know get out of that
how I can I mean I had a 730 credit
score you know and then I had a follow
this bankruptcy and it totally put me
into the Psalms and then I'm always in
pain because my my back I have to get
fusion lower extremities decreased
reflexes and they they twitch on their
own because of the my office he's
squeezing my spine so or a horrible is
my question to use I don't know how to
dig myself out of this how to build my
cricket back up well I don't read it
creditors what to cause your file
bankruptcy we don't need to be in my
head again debt is no fun that didn't
help you here right so what we do need
to do try to build some wealth and get
some margin so that and you've got the
current income plus you're either going
to qualify for these other end
the Social Security and federal and so
forth or which will add to it I mean you
could have a pretty decent disability
income there now the question you want
to ask yourself above that and you're
obviously dealing with a lot of pain but
is there is there any you can start
asking yourself is there anything I can
do that I can make more money than this
disability will pay me and the answer to
that is yes there probably is but if you
can look through the cloud of the the
fog of pain and see it obviously you're
not going to be doing something where
you're lifting with the back like yours
you know but you've got a good mind I've
been talking to you for you know two
segments now your intellectual you you
know you're articulate and so I think
you can appreciate do a lot of things
with your mind that don't involve your
back and that you could maybe even run
some kind of a business that you were
you control your hours so if you're
having a really bad pain day you just
don't work that day you know that kind
of thing but you you could control some
of that with with some some kind of a
thing that you're using your mind to
create income that would be your
long-term thing but as far as bouncing
back you know let's get the incomes
going whatever they are whether the
disability incomes or self-employed
incomes or a new career income that
doesn't involve the disability and then
with that income let's rebuild our lives
and that's what Sharon and I did Tristan
I mean we just said we're starting over
it's been 30 years since our chapter 7
bankruptcy and we said we're going to
learn from the bankruptcy and so what
are we going to do well we're not going
to borrow money anymore it didn't work
for us the borrower is slave to the
lender and we're always going to have
savings lots and lots and lots of
savings in the house of the wise our
stores of choice food and oil and we're
always going to live on a written budget
where every dollar has an assignment no
one gets anywhere big accidentally no
one accidentally becomes wealthy and
stays wealthy now sometimes someone
accidentally buys a winning lotto ticket
but that's that is not a proven method
to begin to build wealth what a proven
method build wealth is you do it on
purpose with a plan and jesus said don't
build a tower without four
counting the cost lest you get halfway
up and you're unable to finish and all
who see you begin to mock you and say
this man began to build it was unable to
finish and that's what happened to me
I built the tower house of cards with no
good plan and it came crashing down
shock of shocks you know and so you
learn your lesson you say you know I'll
never be in a position again with a
credit card where I got
cross-collateralized twice in my
bankruptcy so exactly what you dealt
with there pisses you off at a whole new
level and you know I got I got dealing
with banks and all their little tricks
anything they could pull to you know
take me down and take me out and I'm not
better I'm just really bitter and so I
banks oh it's not what bankers put money
in there or if I'm going to buy the bank
but other than that I want to go in
there so you know I'm the only thing to
do those people anymore I'm never going
to put myself in position that if
someone comes to pick up my cards it's
cause it's broken and I called them to
come get it it's not any other reason
they're coming to get my car and they
did that before and it's no fun seeing
you know someone tow your stuff off
because the borrower slave to the
lenders I'm never gonna be in that
position again and I'm always going to
be in a position to give and be
charitable because there's always
somebody that needs help and you know
you just start having some things that
you say never again and always never
again am i borrowing money and always
I'm going to do a budget never again am
I am I gonna be in a position that this
bank tells me what to do and I'm always
going to be generous and I'm always
going to save and you know you just put
yourself in a position to do those
things so hold on I'm gonna send you
copy the book the Total Money Makeover
which is the plan that we have used to
show millions of people how to come from
where you are where I was or from better
places but all of us heading to a better
place financially living like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else you've been through a real
tough time you financially got your
teeth kicked in and you've been
medically hurt I mean you're hurting
that's too big blows and it knocks the
stuffing out of you but you can come
back you can come back and we'll help
you we're here to help you hold on them
listen you copy the book